The following content is provided under a Creative Commons License. Your support
a Creative Commons License. Your support will help MIT OpenCourseware continue to
will help MIT OpenCourseware continue to offer high-quality educational resources
offer high-quality educational resources for free.
for free. To make a donation or view additional
To make a donation or view additional materials from hundreds of MIT courses,
materials from hundreds of MIT courses, visit MIT OpenCourseware at ocw.mit.edu.
Okay, then let's start with problems and as we find pro as we find concept
as we find pro as we find concept issues, we'll get to concept issues.
issues, we'll get to concept issues. So, we talked about shortest path, but
So, we talked about shortest path, but we talked about shortest paths in a
we talked about shortest paths in a very odd way, right? I'm a coder, so for
very odd way, right? I'm a coder, so for me I'm used to All right, I go to one of
me I'm used to All right, I go to one of these lectures,
these lectures, I hear a problem, then I get out of the
I hear a problem, then I get out of the lecture with an algorithm and a running
lecture with an algorithm and a running time, right?
time, right? This time we got out of the lecture with
This time we got out of the lecture with no algorithm and no running time. So,
no algorithm and no running time. So, what's the point?
what's the point? The point is that we learned some
The point is that we learned some analysis tricks that we can use for any
analysis tricks that we can use for any shortest path algorithm. And the
shortest path algorithm. And the advantage of knowing that, by the way,
advantage of knowing that, by the way, it's really easy to forget, at least
it's really easy to forget, at least until you see the first real algorithms.
until you see the first real algorithms. If you know that, if you have to modify
If you know that, if you have to modify an algorithm,
an algorithm, you can still use the same analysis to
you can still use the same analysis to prove that your new algorithm is going
prove that your new algorithm is going to be correct and that is going to be
to be correct and that is going to be fast.
fast. So, they're really nice tools to have,
So, they're really nice tools to have, especially if you have to do that on a
especially if you have to do that on a problem set or on an interview or who
problem set or on an interview or who knows, maybe even on a quiz.
knows, maybe even on a quiz. So,
So, we'll see if that happens or not.
we'll see if that happens or not. So, we didn't talk about any shortest
So, we didn't talk about any shortest path algorithms. So, we're not going to
path algorithms. So, we're not going to assume shortest path algorithms.
assume shortest path algorithms. Instead, we're going to use them as if
Instead, we're going to use them as if we had them.
No, wait. I don't like that. Uh that's kind of annoying. Let's Let's not do
kind of annoying. Let's Let's not do that. Let's do something else.
that. Let's do something else. We didn't talk about the shortest path
We didn't talk about the shortest path algorithm in lecture. Let's build one
algorithm in lecture. Let's build one right now.
right now. How about that?
How about that? Let's start with a graph.
Let's start with a graph. Vertices and edges, right?
Okay, so suppose we have a graph. We have V vertices, E edges,
have V vertices, E edges, and all the edges have a weight that's
and all the edges have a weight that's non-negative. Sorry, that's Let's make
non-negative. Sorry, that's Let's make it positive just to make things easy.
it positive just to make things easy. It's smaller than W, so it's not too
It's smaller than W, so it's not too big.
big. And they're all integers.
And they're all integers. Go.
There's brute force. There's brute force, okay.
There's brute force, okay. So, brute force would mean what?
So, brute force would mean what? Enumerate all the paths?
Enumerate all the paths? Okay.
Okay. Uh let's go for something a little bit
Uh let's go for something a little bit better.
Does anyone remember the algorithm that was taught in class? The structure? No.
was taught in class? The structure? No. So, class mentioned Dijkstra and
So, class mentioned Dijkstra and mentioned Bellman-Ford.
mentioned Bellman-Ford. Let's write them up here.
Bellman-Ford. And it gave us the running times, which we'll try to remember in a
times, which we'll try to remember in a bit, but we don't know the algorithms.
bit, but we don't know the algorithms. So,
So, no Dijkstra, no Bellman-Ford for us.
no Dijkstra, no Bellman-Ford for us. What do we know?
What do we know? Let's start with a simpler case. What if
Let's start with a simpler case. What if there were no weights here? What if the
there were no weights here? What if the graph looked like this?
Like this. No cost. All the edges have the same
No cost. All the edges have the same cost.
cost. What would we do to solve the problem?
Say we want the shortest path from A to E.
BFS? How's everyone feeling about BFS?
How do you run BFS? Take a starting node and then you search
Take a starting node and then you search all of its neighbors. Okay, so take a
all of its neighbors. Okay, so take a starting node.
starting node. Then look at its neighbors. And then you
Then look at its neighbors. And then you iterate through each of its neighbors to
iterate through each of its neighbors to find its neighbors and
find its neighbors and so forth.
so forth. Sounds an awful lot like DFS. What's the
Sounds an awful lot like DFS. What's the difference between them? Well, um you go
difference between them? Well, um you go through all of A's neighbors before you
through all of A's neighbors before you start going through any of it. I mean,
start going through any of it. I mean, you go through all of A's neighbors
you go through all of A's neighbors before you take a neighbor and go
before you take a neighbor and go through all of its neighbors. Okay,
through all of its neighbors. Okay, that's the difference. And it makes a
that's the difference. And it makes a huge difference as we've seen in
huge difference as we've seen in topological sorting last time.
topological sorting last time. So, we have a list and we're going to
So, we have a list and we're going to use it to keep track of the nodes that
use it to keep track of the nodes that we need to visit. We start with A.
we need to visit. We start with A. We enumerate all of A's neighbors
We enumerate all of A's neighbors and the ones that haven't see haven't
and the ones that haven't see haven't been seen get stuck at the end of the
been seen get stuck at the end of the list.
list. A B C. A is out of the list. Then we
A B C. A is out of the list. Then we take out the first node from the list,
take out the first node from the list, B in this case.
B in this case. We enumerate all its neighbors, A C D E.
We enumerate all its neighbors, A C D E. Out of all these, we take the neighbors
Out of all these, we take the neighbors that we haven't seen and we put them at
that we haven't seen and we put them at the end of the list.
Took out B. We take out C, we look at all its neighbors, we've seen them. We
all its neighbors, we've seen them. We take out D, we look at all its
take out D, we look at all its neighbors, we've seen them. We take out
neighbors, we've seen them. We take out E, we look at all its neighbors, we've
E, we look at all its neighbors, we've seen them.
seen them. So, this is BFS.
So, this is BFS. BFS has this concept of levels. And
BFS has this concept of levels. And another way to look at levels is if you
another way to look at levels is if you start at A
start at A and you draw a circle of radius one,
and you draw a circle of radius one, it's going to have all the nodes that
it's going to have all the nodes that are a distance one from A, right?
are a distance one from A, right? Exactly one edge.
Exactly one edge. Then you draw a circle of radius two
Then you draw a circle of radius two and you get all the nodes that you can
and you get all the nodes that you can reach in two edges.
reach in two edges. And BFS calls these circles levels.
And BFS calls these circles levels. So, A is at level zero, this is level
So, A is at level zero, this is level one, this is level two.
one, this is level two. And if you look at this list and you
And if you look at this list and you write down the levels, you have 0 1 1 2
write down the levels, you have 0 1 1 2 2.
2. If you add another node out here, say F,
this would be discovered when we get to E.
E. So, it would go all the way here at the
So, it would go all the way here at the end and this is level three. So, in BFS
end and this is level three. So, in BFS the levels are always increasing.
the levels are always increasing. So, if you keep track of parent
So, if you keep track of parent pointers,
pointers, the parent pointer of a node at some
the parent pointer of a node at some level will always point to a node at the
level will always point to a node at the previous level.
previous level. So, in BFS we get the shortest paths in
So, in BFS we get the shortest paths in terms of edge count.
Make sense? This is recall, right? It's not new
This is recall, right? It's not new stuff. Everyone happy with it?
stuff. Everyone happy with it? So, if we wouldn't have costs, we could
So, if we wouldn't have costs, we could use BFS to compute shortest paths.
use BFS to compute shortest paths. But we have costs. How do we How do we
But we have costs. How do we How do we deal with that?
deal with that? Intuitively, I'd like to make BFS
Intuitively, I'd like to make BFS go across this edge faster than it would
go across this edge faster than it would go across this edge.
go across this edge. Right? If I could do that, if this guy
Right? If I could do that, if this guy could get stuck in the queue before this
could get stuck in the queue before this guy, I would be happy.
guy, I would be happy. So, intuitively, that's what I'd like to
So, intuitively, that's what I'd like to do.
do. How do we do that?
How do we do that? Sort it before adding.
Sort? Sort your neighbors' weights.
Sort your neighbors' weights. Sort? Okay. So,
Sort? Okay. So, What if you kept track of an adjacency
What if you kept track of an adjacency list?
list? Keep track of your
Keep track of your queue as a priority queue.
queue as a priority queue. Congratulations, you deserve a Turing
Congratulations, you deserve a Turing Award. You have discovered Dijkstra.
Okay, let's go for something simpler. So, what you just said is Dijkstra. You
So, what you just said is Dijkstra. You We'll talk about it in lecture on
We'll talk about it in lecture on Tuesday.
Tuesday. Very good.
I can have an adjacency list and I think using what you said, um
using what you said, um just sort it. So,
just sort it. So, by cost. I mean, Okay, so let's see how
by cost. I mean, Okay, so let's see how this would work. So, we have A
this would work. So, we have A and we're pulling A out of the list and
and we're pulling A out of the list and we see its neighbors are C and B,
we see its neighbors are C and B, right?
right? The distance to C is two, the distance
The distance to C is two, the distance to B is four.
to B is four. So, we start with A.
So, does this mean that I'm going to put in B before C? And then So, I'm going to
in B before C? And then So, I'm going to put in C and then B?
put in C and then B? Well, I mean,
Well, I mean, it doesn't really matter. You just at
it doesn't really matter. You just at the end you just sort.
the end you just sort. I guess you could add the
I guess you could add the costs, like associate the cost of B with
costs, like associate the cost of B with four and C with two
four and C with two within your adjacency list.
within your adjacency list. Okay, so that's how we would keep track
Okay, so that's how we would keep track of costs, right? One way. For the key
of costs, right? One way. For the key would be A and then the value would be
would be A and then the value would be like a tuple of B and its cost and then
like a tuple of B and its cost and then a tuple of C and its cost.
a tuple of C and its cost. Okay, so you're saying that what I would
Okay, so you're saying that what I would have in this list is
have in this list is B with a cost of four
B with a cost of four and C with a cost of
and C with a cost of two?
two? Presumably in the other
Presumably in the other other way around, right? C goes first.
Like this? And then I take out C, I explore the
And then I take out C, I explore the neighbors so on and so forth?
neighbors so on and so forth? The moment I did this, I already lost
The moment I did this, I already lost the battle because
See this path? Uh ACB, length three.
Uh ACB, length three. If I put both of them in the queue, then
If I put both of them in the queue, then the parent pointers are going to look
the parent pointers are going to look like this.
like this. So, I already have a bad path from B to
So, I already have a bad path from B to A. Okay, well don't add that node then.
A. Okay, well don't add that node then. Okay, then how How do we do it? Um
Okay, then how How do we do it? Um I guess
I guess Well, you can you can talk to each of
Well, you can you can talk to each of them and see which one's lower and then
them and see which one's lower and then only add that one if it's the lowest.
only add that one if it's the lowest. And then you keep it So, it's more like
And then you keep it So, it's more like depth-first search then. Well, you two
depth-first search then. Well, you two need to talk together because that you
need to talk together because that you you're getting to Dijkstra, too. You're
you're getting to Dijkstra, too. You're You're both going to rediscover
You're both going to rediscover Dijkstra.
Dijkstra. So,
So, so that's great, but I'm looking for
so that's great, but I'm looking for something simple. So, this is too
something simple. So, this is too complicated. If you're If you're going
complicated. If you're If you're going to do Dijkstra now, then what are we
to do Dijkstra now, then what are we going to do on lecture on Tuesday?
going to do on lecture on Tuesday? More Dijkstra problems?
Well, I I think Srini wants to talk about Dijkstra, so let's not get there.
about Dijkstra, so let's not get there. Wait, how do you do this without doing
Wait, how do you do this without doing Dijkstra?
Dijkstra? That That's exactly what I want to know.
So, let me give you another hint. So, the first hint was that I want to go
the first hint was that I want to go through this edge faster than I would go
through this edge faster than I would go through this edge.
through this edge. The other hint is that we're allowed to
The other hint is that we're allowed to change the graph.
change the graph. So, I mean, for each node I mean, is
So, I mean, for each node I mean, is this what we were talking about in
this what we were talking about in lecture, or are you thinking of
lecture, or are you thinking of something else? What uh
something else? What uh He might have uh talked about that at
He might have uh talked about that at the end of lecture.
I mean, where where you're putting the current weight
the current weight for each node
for each node inside the circles.
inside the circles. No. Oh, okay.
No. Oh, okay. You could add it, and then just if you
You could add it, and then just if you find a better path to B,
find a better path to B, if you're always relative to A, then you
if you're always relative to A, then you could just delete that path.
could just delete that path. It'd be a four.
It'd be a four. So, at the beginning add them all, but
So, at the beginning add them all, but then You're risking to have exponential
then You're risking to have exponential running time.
Those are all valid optimizations under some constraints. Like, this one's good
some constraints. Like, this one's good if you're willing if you don't have too
if you're willing if you don't have too much memory, but the time goes up.
much memory, but the time goes up. So, I want my graph to have edges with
So, I want my graph to have edges with no costs. If If I have costs, this is
no costs. If If I have costs, this is not going to work. BFS is not going to
not going to work. BFS is not going to work.
work. We can't tweak it. If we could tweak it,
We can't tweak it. If we could tweak it, then that would be another Turing award.
then that would be another Turing award. So, like create dummy nodes?
So, like create dummy nodes? Create dummy nodes? How do I do that?
Put a dummy node in between A and C. Okay. Why am I doing this?
So, now I have two edges, and they have costs.
costs. One.
One. Then you put three nodes in between A
Then you put three nodes in between A and B.
and B. Okay.
Okay. Or yeah, three.
Or yeah, three. And now here I have four edges, right?
And now here I have four edges, right? One, one, one, one. There was a four
One, one, one, one. There was a four here before, and there was a two here
here before, and there was a two here before.
Do you guys see what's happening? So, instead of one edge of cost C, I
So, instead of one edge of cost C, I have C edges. So, now BFS is going to
have C edges. So, now BFS is going to take C steps
take C steps to go through that edge.
to go through that edge. And all the edges now have the same
And all the edges now have the same cost. So, this looks like a problem that
cost. So, this looks like a problem that BFS can solve. We know it can solve. We
BFS can solve. We know it can solve. We proved that it can solve it. Well, CLRS
proved that it can solve it. Well, CLRS did. We take their word for granted,
did. We take their word for granted, sort of.
sort of. So,
this works, right? Is everyone happy with it? Does it make
Is everyone happy with it? Does it make sense?
sense? So, basically you get to You get to B
So, basically you get to You get to B before you ever get
before you ever get to I mean, through C before you'll get
to I mean, through C before you'll get to B. You'll get in the path. Yep. So,
to B. You'll get in the path. Yep. So, this is a path of length three. So, this
this is a path of length three. So, this node is going to get in the queue first,
node is going to get in the queue first, then this node, then these two nodes.
then this node, then these two nodes. And they're going to get in the queue
And they're going to get in the queue from C.
So, let's see what happened here. So, this is really important because this is
this is really important because this is what you're going to be doing in real
what you're going to be doing in real life.
life. Chances of having to build a new
Chances of having to build a new algorithm kind of slim. Why don't you
algorithm kind of slim. Why don't you want to do that? Say you take Dijkstra,
want to do that? Say you take Dijkstra, and you tweak it a little bit.
and you tweak it a little bit. If you did that, you have to go through
If you did that, you have to go through the analysis and prove the running time
the analysis and prove the running time again, prove the correctness again.
again, prove the correctness again. Time-consuming, error-prone, it's really
Time-consuming, error-prone, it's really hard.
hard. However, what happened here is that we
However, what happened here is that we have some problem that we want to solve.
have some problem that we want to solve. Say we have the raw input for that
Say we have the raw input for that problem that we're trying to solve.
That is this graph that I drew on the board.
And we apply some transform, and we get an input that's suitable for
and we get an input that's suitable for an algorithm that we already know.
And I'm I'm going to take a shortcut here
I'm I'm going to take a shortcut here because I don't
So, we apply the transform, right? We took this graph and we built a new graph
took this graph and we built a new graph N.
N. And this is hopefully easy.
And this is hopefully easy. Right? Take a Take an edge and split it
Right? Take a Take an edge and split it up, put in fake nodes. This is easy. We
up, put in fake nodes. This is easy. We know how to code that.
know how to code that. And now we have this algorithm that we
And now we have this algorithm that we already know, and we're treating it like
already know, and we're treating it like a black box.
We know it's correct. We know it's running time. We're not questioning
running time. We're not questioning them. We're taking them straight from
them. We're taking them straight from the textbook. They have to be right. By
the textbook. They have to be right. By the way, what's the running time of BFS?
Uh and sorry?
and sorry? V log V Very good.
V log V Very good. I can hear you very well.
So, then BFS is going to give us a path, right? And the path is going to look
right? And the path is going to look like this. It's going to be
like this. It's going to be uh A, fake node, C, D,
If you give this back to the guy who gave you the problem, they're going to
gave you the problem, they're going to be like, "What are these fake nodes? I
be like, "What are these fake nodes? I don't know anything about them. This
don't know anything about them. This doesn't make sense."
doesn't make sense." So, you need to take this
So, you need to take this raw output,
raw output, and you need to transform it again.
and you need to transform it again. Based on what you did on this
Based on what you did on this transformation, you have to read out the
transformation, you have to read out the output. You have to interpret it.
output. You have to interpret it. So, this is either interpret or read
So, this is either interpret or read out. And then you get a nice output
out. And then you get a nice output that's the output to your original
that's the output to your original problem.
This process here is the most likely way in which you'll
is the most likely way in which you'll use your 606 knowledge. And this is
use your 606 knowledge. And this is replaced by any algorithm that we
replaced by any algorithm that we taught.
taught. This is replaced by any real-life
This is replaced by any real-life problem that you'll encounter.
problem that you'll encounter. Okay.
Okay. So,
So, there's one missing step here. We know
there's one missing step here. We know the running time for this. Let's find
the running time for this. Let's find out the running time for the whole
out the running time for the whole thing.
thing. So, in order to do that, we have to
So, in order to do that, we have to figure out given this original graph,
figure out given this original graph, let's say that now in the original graph
let's say that now in the original graph we have V prime vertices, E prime edges,
we have V prime vertices, E prime edges, and W prime weights.
and W prime weights. We have to convert this into V plus E.
We have to convert this into V plus E. So, we have to see when we make this
So, we have to see when we make this transform, how many vertices do we get?
transform, how many vertices do we get? How many edges do we get in terms of the
How many edges do we get in terms of the original graph, so that we can compute
original graph, so that we can compute the running time.
the running time. So, in the original graph V prime
So, in the original graph V prime vertices, E prime edges, W prime
vertices, E prime edges, W prime weights. In this new graph, how many
weights. In this new graph, how many edges do I have?
edges do I have? At most.
Sorry? Yep, perfect.
So, each edge has cost at most W. So, that
each edge has cost at most W. So, that means we're going to split it up into at
means we're going to split it up into at most W edges.
most W edges. How many vertices are we going to have?
Plus V prime. Don't forget about the original ones.
Don't forget about the original ones. They're still there.
They're still there. Okay. So, total running time for BFS on
Okay. So, total running time for BFS on this new graph is
Okay. I'll put it the other way around. Plus W prime
Plus W prime E prime.
Okay. So, this is the running time that we have.
we have. Now, does anyone remember Dijkstra's
Now, does anyone remember Dijkstra's running time and Bellman-Ford's running
running time and Bellman-Ford's running time?
So, what's the running time for Dijkstra?
Dijkstra? V log V plus E.
V log V plus E. Uh almost.
Uh almost. V log V
V log V Oh, wait. Oh, yeah. You I think you're
Oh, wait. Oh, yeah. You I think you're right.
right. V log V plus
V log V plus E
Are you reading this from CLRS? Or is this what we got? It's what they
Or is this what we got? It's what they They gave They gave in the book. You
They gave They gave in the book. You need to use a fancy heap to get this
need to use a fancy heap to get this running time.
running time. Yeah. You can get this, but you need a
Yeah. You can get this, but you need a really fancy data structure for it. In
really fancy data structure for it. In real life, the running time looks more
real life, the running time looks more like
like E log V.
E log V. Okay. And how about Bellman-Ford?
Okay. So, let's take this running time for Dijkstra because this is what you're
for Dijkstra because this is what you're going to implement in real life, and we
going to implement in real life, and we can argue about that after next lecture.
can argue about that after next lecture. For now, take my word for it.
For now, take my word for it. And let's compare it to what we got
And let's compare it to what we got here.
here. V is smaller than E in most sane cases.
V is smaller than E in most sane cases. So, let's say that this is actually W
So, let's say that this is actually W prime E prime.
prime E prime. So, if you compare this with this,
So, if you compare this with this, you'll see that if W is smaller than log
you'll see that if W is smaller than log V,
V, well, smaller or equal, then this
well, smaller or equal, then this algorithm is not worse than Dijkstra.
algorithm is not worse than Dijkstra. It's on on par with Dijkstra.
It's on on par with Dijkstra. So, for graphs with small costs, we
So, for graphs with small costs, we discovered an algorithm that solves
discovered an algorithm that solves shortest paths.
shortest paths. We
We walked in this recitation knowing no
walked in this recitation knowing no algorithm to solve shortest path.
algorithm to solve shortest path. Now we have an algorithm. Already in a
Now we have an algorithm. Already in a much better position.
much better position. Right? And we didn't invent anything
Right? And we didn't invent anything new. We don't have to prove correctness.
new. We don't have to prove correctness. All we did was one of these
All we did was one of these transformations.
transformations. Okay. How's everyone feeling?
Do the things make sense? Everyone happy?
Okay, let's talk about another problem that
that also uses this structure.
So, suppose we have the same graph that we had before, or actually any graph
we had before, or actually any graph with
with V vertices, E edges.
V vertices, E edges. Now, we know how to compute shortest
Now, we know how to compute shortest path. So, we can assume
path. So, we can assume these as black boxes.
So, we're going to use these as they are.
are. So, we have a graph with V vertices and
So, we have a graph with V vertices and E edges.
A B C D E
E And let me copy the costs really
And let me copy the costs really quickly.
quickly. 4 2 1 2
4 2 1 2 1
So, suppose this is a highway system. Right? Like in Google Maps.
Right? Like in Google Maps. And we have two brothers. They start off
And we have two brothers. They start off from a place
from a place and they have to end up in another
and they have to end up in another place. They're going to drive together.
place. They're going to drive together. Uh they want this to be sort of fair.
Uh they want this to be sort of fair. So,
So, every time they go between two cities,
every time they go between two cities, they're going to switch seats.
they're going to switch seats. So, that none of them drives too much.
So, that none of them drives too much. So, say the brothers are Tim and Jim.
So, say the brothers are Tim and Jim. The names are wrong. This is actually a
The names are wrong. This is actually a problem for from last year's quiz.
problem for from last year's quiz. So, by the way, real problem. You can
So, by the way, real problem. You can pay attention now.
pay attention now. So, these are two brothers.
So, these are two brothers. They They're going to alternate, right?
They They're going to alternate, right? One of them's going to drive across one
One of them's going to drive across one road, then the other one, then the first
road, then the other one, then the first one, then the second one, so on and so
one, then the second one, so on and so forth.
forth. Now,
Now, Tim has a much better sense of direction
Tim has a much better sense of direction than Jim.
than Jim. That's just how things are. And if you
That's just how things are. And if you ever driven long distances,
ever driven long distances, the hardest thing to do is to get from
the hardest thing to do is to get from the city to the highway.
the city to the highway. So, like if you have to drive from here
So, like if you have to drive from here to New York, hardest thing to do, get
to New York, hardest thing to do, get out of Boston and onto the highway.
out of Boston and onto the highway. Then, at the end, hardest thing to do,
Then, at the end, hardest thing to do, get from the highway into where you want
get from the highway into where you want to go through New York traffic.
to go through New York traffic. Everything else, piece of cake.
Everything else, piece of cake. So, we want Tim to handle both of these
So, we want Tim to handle both of these situations.
situations. So,
So, the driving path must start with Tim and
the driving path must start with Tim and must end with Tim.
must end with Tim. Otherwise, God knows, they're going to
Otherwise, God knows, they're going to crash.
crash. So, let's First off, let's convert this
So, let's First off, let's convert this into graph terms. And then, let's solve
into graph terms. And then, let's solve it.
Well, so this I have this constraint that
this I have this constraint that they're going to switch seats and that
they're going to switch seats and that Tim has to start and Tim has to end. How
Tim has to start and Tim has to end. How do I phrase this in mathy terms? In
do I phrase this in mathy terms? In graph terms?
Um we're starting at where and they where
we're starting at where and they where We're given where in the graph. So, so
We're given where in the graph. So, so we're starting at S ending at T.
we're starting at S ending at T. Some points in the graph.
Some points in the graph. And
And people have to drive the an entire edge.
people have to drive the an entire edge. Is that correct? Yeah.
Is that correct? Yeah. Okay, so then So, basically Yeah.
Okay, so then So, basically Yeah. Jim has to
Jim has to Wait, whoever the good driver has to
Wait, whoever the good driver has to drive on the edge that's adjacent to E
drive on the edge that's adjacent to E and S.
and S. Yep. Okay.
Yep. Okay. You basically need like an odd number of
You basically need like an odd number of edges. Yep.
edges. Yep. So, I want the shortest path with an odd
So, I want the shortest path with an odd number of edges.
number of edges. Why odd number of edges? If we look at
Why odd number of edges? If we look at the edges, Tim's going to take the first
the edges, Tim's going to take the first one, then Jim, then Tim, then Jim, then
one, then Jim, then Tim, then Jim, then Tim, then Jim, and no matter how many I
Tim, then Jim, and no matter how many I have here, it has to end with Tim.
have here, it has to end with Tim. So, I'm going to have an odd number of
So, I'm going to have an odd number of letters here. Therefore, odd number of
letters here. Therefore, odd number of edges.
edges. Right? So, I want the shortest path
Right? So, I want the shortest path that has an
that has an odd number of edges.
And that's the hint. We're going to use that trick over there. So, yes. But, the
that trick over there. So, yes. But, the shortest path isn't necessarily like the
shortest path isn't necessarily like the fairest, right? Like in terms of
fairest, right? Like in terms of distributing
distributing driving.
driving. Uh one of them's going to drive one more
Uh one of them's going to drive one more road.
road. Such is life. Well, sorry, one more edge
Such is life. Well, sorry, one more edge segment. So, Tim's going to drive, say,
segment. So, Tim's going to drive, say, Tim's going to drive three times, Jim is
Tim's going to drive three times, Jim is going to drive two times.
going to drive two times. Right, but like in terms of the weights
Right, but like in terms of the weights Oh, yeah, we don't care about that.
Jim doesn't know where he's going anyways. So, the minimum you need is a
anyways. So, the minimum you need is a length of like three paths, right?
length of like three paths, right? Cuz you don't want to Tim to get out to
Cuz you don't want to Tim to get out to the highway and be like, "Oh, look, I'm
the highway and be like, "Oh, look, I'm driving it's not that far." And then So,
driving it's not that far." And then So, I want the shortest
I want the shortest So, I want to the path with the the
So, I want to the path with the the smallest cost.
smallest cost. Okay. So, smallest total weight.
Okay. So, smallest total weight. But, I mean like
But, I mean like in theory, it could be length two,
in theory, it could be length two, right? Cuz Well, if it's length two,
right? Cuz Well, if it's length two, then it's not going to be good because
then it's not going to be good because they're going to crash.
they're going to crash. Well, no, like Tim would Oh, I see. They
Well, no, like Tim would Oh, I see. They have to switch every time. Yep.
have to switch every time. Yep. Tim can't drive for two consecutive
Tim can't drive for two consecutive edges. Okay.
I mean, you could use breadth-first search and
search and um and check once you get to the end
um and check once you get to the end point, eliminate all paths that are
point, eliminate all paths that are um
um you know, even length.
you know, even length. And then those paths, go through them to
And then those paths, go through them to see if
see if it comes to the lowest cost. So, you're
it comes to the lowest cost. So, you're thinking enumerate all paths of even
thinking enumerate all paths of even length?
length? No, just to make sure I got it. Yeah.
No, just to make sure I got it. Yeah. So, this is cool because it let it lets
So, this is cool because it let it lets me show something else that's cool. So,
me show something else that's cool. So, I'll enumerate all paths of even length.
I'll enumerate all paths of even length. Um something else I heard, enumerate all
Um something else I heard, enumerate all the shortest path.
the shortest path. For both of these, let's look at this
For both of these, let's look at this graph.
S T All the paths have length one.
How many ways are there to get from S to T?
T? Four.
Two to the three. Two ways to go across this diamond, two
Two ways to go across this diamond, two ways to go across ways to go across this
ways to go across ways to go across this one, two ways to go across this one.
one, two ways to go across this one. Right?
Right? 2 * 2 * 2 8
2 * 2 * 2 8 If I add another diamond,
how many paths? One more?
Okay. So, the number of even paths or the number of shortest paths, the number
the number of shortest paths, the number of
of whatever paths I can think about is
whatever paths I can think about is order of
It's two to the number of diamonds. Okay, which is
N related to the vertices, right?
Exponential in the number of vertices. Not very good. Not very good. We can't
Not very good. Not very good. We can't do this.
So, it's better that we talked about it here than then you try to do it on the
here than then you try to do it on the quiz and you have to discover this on
quiz and you have to discover this on your own, right? So, good comment. Do
your own, right? So, good comment. Do you understand what he meant by that
you understand what he meant by that lecture? So,
lecture? So, That's completely different. That's
That's completely different. That's another
another That's the other thing he's talking
That's the other thing he's talking about. That's different. That wasn't the
about. That's different. That wasn't the question.
question. Yeah, that's that's where relaxation can
Yeah, that's that's where relaxation can go wrong. So, he showed that if you
go wrong. So, he showed that if you relax the edges in a random order, you
relax the edges in a random order, you can have an exponential number of steps.
This shows that there are an exponential number of paths for any graph, no matter
number of paths for any graph, no matter how good your algorithm is.
Okay, so we're not going to be able to enumerate them. Let's try something
enumerate them. Let's try something else.
Any suggestions? Uh Look at all the shortest paths.
Uh Look at all the shortest paths. So, you So, you're doing this, right?
So, you So, you're doing this, right? You were looking here.
You were looking here. You're Everyone's looking here.
You're Everyone's looking here. How about this?
Should do that? There There's that, right? There's a
There There's that, right? There's a transform. You need to transform your
transform. You need to transform your graph in some way and then run the
graph in some way and then run the algorithm and then reading off the
algorithm and then reading off the output should be easy.
output should be easy. I claim that the hard step is the
I claim that the hard step is the transform step, not the read off step.
Okay, so let me give you one more piece of intuition.
So, we're going to keep track of state somehow. So, remember Rubik's Cube?
somehow. So, remember Rubik's Cube? We had one vertex for each state, right?
We had one vertex for each state, right? A state represented a configuration of
A state represented a configuration of the cube.
the cube. Here, suppose I got
Here, suppose I got from
from I'm looking at a path from S to D.
I'm looking at a path from S to D. The problem that I have with this is
The problem that I have with this is that
that if I have an algorithm that tells me the
if I have an algorithm that tells me the shortest path from S to D is something,
shortest path from S to D is something, I don't know if it's even or if it's
I don't know if it's even or if it's odd. It's not keeping track of that.
odd. It's not keeping track of that. So, it's missing some state. The state
So, it's missing some state. The state that it's missing is whether the path
that it's missing is whether the path that I used to get here is even or odd
that I used to get here is even or odd length.
length. So, I should do something to the graph
So, I should do something to the graph to keep track of the state.
So, can you BFS once to find
So, like right cuz if you BFS once, then you know that B and C are all
you know that B and C are all like one way and then you know that E
like one way and then you know that E and G are two way.
and G are two way. Uh
Uh Well, B might be two away if I take this
Well, B might be two away if I take this path.
path. So, it might be one away, it might be
So, it might be one away, it might be two away.
But, this is good. So, this is what you'll do on the quiz, right? You come
you'll do on the quiz, right? You come up with an idea
up with an idea and then you're going to think about it
and then you're going to think about it for a bit. If you get stuck,
for a bit. If you get stuck, try to convince yourself that it's
try to convince yourself that it's wrong, or just if things get too hard,
wrong, or just if things get too hard, discard and look somewhere else.
discard and look somewhere else. So, this is thought process, right? You
So, this is thought process, right? You think of something, backtrack,
think of something, backtrack, backtrack, backtrack, and eventually you
backtrack, backtrack, and eventually you get to the right solution.
So, let's go over the solution for this one, and then I'll give you a hard one
one, and then I'll give you a hard one that is sort of like this, and then I'll
that is sort of like this, and then I'll want the solution from you for that one.
want the solution from you for that one. So, I'm going to draw this graph in a
So, I'm going to draw this graph in a bigger version. So, I'll have to erase
bigger version. So, I'll have to erase this.
So, this is a cool concept. You will be able to do a lot of things
You will be able to do a lot of things with it.
with it. But, is this problem solvable by
But, is this problem solvable by Dijkstra?
Dijkstra? Yeah.
Yeah. Okay, I'm just curious. Yeah, we'll run
Okay, I'm just curious. Yeah, we'll run Dijkstra on it after we transform it.
These are big nodes, right? Why am I doing it this way?
doing it this way? They're like Seattle, Portland, San
They're like Seattle, Portland, San Francisco. Uh-huh.
Francisco. Uh-huh. It's because I'm going to need room for
It's because I'm going to need room for copies.
copies. I'm going to make a copy of each node to
I'm going to make a copy of each node to keep track of state.
keep track of state. So, instead of one node, I'll have two
So, instead of one node, I'll have two nodes for each node.
nodes for each node. And I have two nodes because this is
And I have two nodes because this is what lets me keep track of state, odd
what lets me keep track of state, odd path or even path.
Let me erase the edges because that's not how it's going to work, actually.
So, instead of having a node A, I'm going to have a node
going to have a node A even, and I'm going to have a copy
A even, and I'm going to have a copy A odd.
B even, I'm going to have a copy
I'm going to have a copy B odd.
B odd. C even,
C even, copy it
copy it to C odd.
to C odd. D even,
make a copy to D odd. Uh wait, this is E. Sorry. Sorry, my
Uh wait, this is E. Sorry. Sorry, my bad.
Okay, so suppose I got to A
to A using an even length path.
using an even length path. If I take the edge from A to B,
If I take the edge from A to B, I will get to B using an even length
I will get to B using an even length path or an odd length path?
path or an odd length path? Odd.
Odd. So, if I get to A using an even length
So, if I get to A using an even length path, then from there I'll get to B
path, then from there I'll get to B using an odd length path.
using an odd length path. Sorry, for using this exact
Sorry, for using this exact road.
That's a nice way to name it. I've heard worse.
I've heard worse. So, if I get to A using an odd number of
So, if I get to A using an odd number of edges,
edges, how many edges will I have when I get to
how many edges will I have when I get to B?
B? Even.
Even. Okay.
Okay. So, this edge became these edges here.
Okay, now let's do the edge between B and E.
and E. I get to B using an even number of
I get to B using an even number of edges.
edges. I take B,
I take B, do I get to E even to or to E odd? Odd.
What are the lengths of these paths? Five. Five.
Five. Five. Okay.
Okay. Cool.
Cool. Uh
Uh God, this is starting to look uglier,
God, this is starting to look uglier, right?
right? Uh let's do AC and stop there.
Uh let's do AC and stop there. Um
Um A even is connected to
A even is connected to C odd by a path of length
C odd by a path of length Two.
Two. And A odd is connected to C even by a
And A odd is connected to C even by a path of length Three.
I mean, you want you you just So, all the edges are going to look like this.
the edges are going to look like this. So, are those like two independent
So, are those like two independent graphs?
graphs? Uh well, I have well, I have edges
Uh well, I have well, I have edges connecting them, but I I like your
connecting them, but I I like your question. So, the reason this is ugly
question. So, the reason this is ugly is because I'm looking at a 2D
is because I'm looking at a 2D projection of a 3D graph.
projection of a 3D graph. If I had a holographic display, which
If I had a holographic display, which would be a lot nicer, then I would do
would be a lot nicer, then I would do something along these lines. I would
something along these lines. I would say, hmm,
say, hmm, two pieces of paper.
two pieces of paper. I would draw the graph, I would draw the
I would draw the graph, I would draw the original graph, and call it the even
original graph, and call it the even graph, put it here.
graph, put it here. I would draw the graph again, call it
I would draw the graph again, call it the odd graph, and put it here.
the odd graph, and put it here. So, this is my 2D graph. This is my map,
So, this is my 2D graph. This is my map, the original map.
the original map. And this is state. The third dimension
And this is state. The third dimension is state.
is state. So, when I start
So, when I start when I when I'm at a node, and I used an
when I when I'm at a node, and I used an even number of edges to get here,
even number of edges to get here, I'm going to go take one edge
I'm going to go take one edge and go to another node using an odd
and go to another node using an odd number of edges.
number of edges. So, all the edges are going to go from
So, all the edges are going to go from here to here, and from here to here.
Does it make more sense now? So, the reason that looks ugly is
So, the reason that looks ugly is because you're seeing the graph like
because you're seeing the graph like this.
this. If you could see like this, and maybe
If you could see like this, and maybe play with it a little bit,
play with it a little bit, it would make more sense. It wouldn't
it would make more sense. It wouldn't look as ugly.
So, there are two graphs, the even graph and the odd graph, and the edges between
and the odd graph, and the edges between them represent
them represent you doing something.
you doing something. So, when you transition when you take a
So, when you transition when you take a highway, you transition from an even
highway, you transition from an even state to an odd state, and from an odd
state to an odd state, and from an odd state to an even state. So, that's why
state to an even state. So, that's why the edges are the way they are.
the edges are the way they are. Okay, so now let me see if you guys get
Okay, so now let me see if you guys get it. What node do I start from? What node
it. What node do I start from? What node do I want to end up in?
Okay. Oh, there's two odds. Yeah.
Oh, there's two odds. Yeah. Okay, so I heard three answers. One of
Okay, so I heard three answers. One of them's correct.
them's correct. Do you want to vote, or do you guys want
Do you want to vote, or do you guys want to figure it out?
to figure it out? Talk it out.
Talk it out. Fight.
We start from A even, and we end up at E odd. Why do I start at A even?
Yep, so the original path has length zero, which happens to be even.
zero, which happens to be even. And we want to end up with an odd length
And we want to end up with an odd length path.
path. So, if we go from here to here, see how
So, if we go from here to here, see how because we have two nodes instead of
because we have two nodes instead of each original node, the path is going to
each original node, the path is going to alternate between even and odd, and it's
alternate between even and odd, and it's going to keep track of the state that I
going to keep track of the state that I didn't have before, and it's going to
didn't have before, and it's going to just do the right thing?
just do the right thing? It's magic. It works.
It's magic. It works. So,
So, let's see what's the running time of
let's see what's the running time of this new algorithm.
this new algorithm. How many
How many uh say my original graph had V and E.
uh say my original graph had V and E. How many new vertices do I have?
Each edge is copied exactly twice. Which algorithm am I going to use? All my
algorithm am I going to use? All my weights are positive because they're the
weights are positive because they're the time it takes to drive somewhere, or the
time it takes to drive somewhere, or the distance, or something. So, which
distance, or something. So, which algorithm do I use?
Um you can't use breadth-first search
you can't use breadth-first search because you have weights.
because you have weights. So, breadth-first search is not going to
So, breadth-first search is not going to find the right answer.
find the right answer. Oh, you you want to use this thing.
Oh, you you want to use this thing. Well, so we don't have to worry about
Well, so we don't have to worry about that because now we put the shortest
that because now we put the shortest path algorithm in a black box, and we
path algorithm in a black box, and we have them.
have them. Yeah, so we use these black boxes. But,
Yeah, so we use these black boxes. But, what we need to know is when to use this
what we need to know is when to use this black box, and when to use this black
black box, and when to use this black box. Which box is faster, by the way?
box. Which box is faster, by the way? Please please give me the right answer.
All right, Dijkstra is faster. So, whenever we can use Dijkstra, we
So, whenever we can use Dijkstra, we will use Dijkstra. When can't we use
will use Dijkstra. When can't we use Dijkstra?
Negative negative weights.
negative weights. So,
So, if I have
if I have weights greater or equal to zero, I'm
weights greater or equal to zero, I'm happy I can use Dijkstra. If I have
happy I can use Dijkstra. If I have weights that are smaller than zero,
weights that are smaller than zero, well, whatever. It's going to be slower,
well, whatever. It's going to be slower, but I can still solve it. It's like
but I can still solve it. It's like arbitrary negative weights, right?
arbitrary negative weights, right? Yep.
Yep. Arbitrary negative weights.
So, all the edges here are positive, so I'm going to use
Dijkstra, very good. So, the running time will be
time will be order of
V log V plus E if you're a theory person. If you're in
if you're a theory person. If you're in real life, it's E log V.
So, hey, this is exactly the running time for the original graph.
time for the original graph. So, the transformation only increased
So, the transformation only increased the graph size by a constant factor, so
the graph size by a constant factor, so same running time.
same running time. Pretty good, right?
Okay, let's do one more problem. Let's do the hard problem now.
Are you guys getting ready for the hard problem?
Well, that's why I that's why we taught that's why we taught you this.
that's why we taught you this. So, I wanted to do two things. I wanted
So, I wanted to do two things. I wanted to show you that trick, which is a cool
to show you that trick, which is a cool trick, keep track of
trick, keep track of state by doubling or by multiplying the
state by doubling or by multiplying the vertices that you have.
vertices that you have. And I wanted to go through some wrong
And I wanted to go through some wrong solutions and figure out why they're
solutions and figure out why they're wrong, so you can develop an intuition.
wrong, so you can develop an intuition. Because when you're going to get a new
Because when you're going to get a new problem, you're going to think of
problem, you're going to think of something. Unless you're really good,
something. Unless you're really good, unless you're destined to win a Turing
unless you're destined to win a Turing award of some sort, the first solution
award of some sort, the first solution will probably be wrong. Even if you're
will probably be wrong. Even if you're destined to win a Turing award, the
destined to win a Turing award, the first thing that comes to mind will
first thing that comes to mind will probably be wrong. I'm willing to bet
probably be wrong. I'm willing to bet Dijkstra didn't think of Dijkstra off
Dijkstra didn't think of Dijkstra off the top of his head when he heard about
the top of his head when he heard about the problem. So,
the problem. So, what you want to do is get an intuition.
what you want to do is get an intuition. So, when you think of a solution and it
So, when you think of a solution and it starts getting complicated or things
starts getting complicated or things start looking wrong, you want to back
start looking wrong, you want to back out and think of something else. The
out and think of something else. The more things you can consider, higher
more things you can consider, higher chances that you're going to stumble
chances that you're going to stumble upon the correct solution. So, that's
upon the correct solution. So, that's why we're building an intuition for bad
why we're building an intuition for bad solutions.
solutions. I'm not I'm not just saying, "Hey, give
I'm not I'm not just saying, "Hey, give me a solution and now I'll tell you it's
me a solution and now I'll tell you it's wrong." It's not just to embarrass you
wrong." It's not just to embarrass you or something. There's that intuition
or something. There's that intuition building stuff that's really important.
building stuff that's really important. Okay, so there's this network that we
Okay, so there's this network that we keep talking about.
keep talking about. There's this highway network, except
There's this highway network, except this time it's a bit more complicated.
So, for each edge, I have two things.
I have two things. I have a fuel cost,
I have a fuel cost, which is constant.
which is constant. So, a fuel cost is a function of the
So, a fuel cost is a function of the length of the road.
length of the road. But now I have these realistic highways
But now I have these realistic highways where I have traffic. If you try to go
where I have traffic. If you try to go from Boston to New York, 2:00 a.m., 3
from Boston to New York, 2:00 a.m., 3 hours.
hours. Rush hour, 6 hours.
Rush hour, 6 hours. So, we have to keep track of this in
So, we have to keep track of this in some way.
some way. Well, we're going to split up the day
Well, we're going to split up the day into minutes.
into minutes. Say you have M minutes in a day. Can
Say you have M minutes in a day. Can anyone tell me what M is really quickly?
anyone tell me what M is really quickly? Not a number, a formula, something.
Not a number, a formula, something. What's isn't it What's 3,600 * 24?
I'm not sure. Okay.
Okay. 12 * 60.
12 * 60. All right.
All right. So, this is how many minutes in a day.
So, this is how many minutes we have in a day, right?
a day, right? Okay, so we're going for each edge,
Okay, so we're going for each edge, we're going to have a function that's
we're going to have a function that's the time cost of the edge.
the time cost of the edge. So, it's the time cost of this edge,
So, it's the time cost of this edge, and it's going to say, "If I started a
and it's going to say, "If I started a certain time, it's going to take this
certain time, it's going to take this many minutes to go across the edge."
many minutes to go across the edge." So, for each street, I know how much
So, for each street, I know how much time it Sorry, each highway, I know how
time it Sorry, each highway, I know how much time it's going to take to go
much time it's going to take to go across it, given when I start,
across it, given when I start, and I know how much fuel I'm going to
and I know how much fuel I'm going to consume.
consume. By the way, edges are directed now, just
By the way, edges are directed now, just to make our life easy. So,
to make our life easy. So, this is this graph is going to be
like this. Let's see if I can get this right.
Let's see if I can get this right. It's actually like Boston where they've
It's actually like Boston where they've got one-ways everywhere.
got one-ways everywhere. Well, so the real reason I'm having this
Well, so the real reason I'm having this is uh the
is uh the the time to go across the street might
the time to go across the street might be different across highway might be
be different across highway might be different depending which way you go.
different depending which way you go. Oh, so you see Getting into Boston in
Oh, so you see Getting into Boston in the morning versus getting into Boston
the morning versus getting into Boston in the evening, which one's easier?
in the evening, which one's easier? Sorry, versus getting out of Boston in
Sorry, versus getting out of Boston in the morning.
the morning. Intuitively, I'd say it's probably
Intuitively, I'd say it's probably harder to get in in the morning as
harder to get in in the morning as people are going to work.
people are going to work. And it's easier to get out. But yeah, I
And it's easier to get out. But yeah, I don't know either. No, the 95 tolls are
don't know either. No, the 95 tolls are brutal.
brutal. Okay,
Okay, we have an answer.
we have an answer. Okay, so our edges are going to be
Okay, so our edges are going to be oriented,
oriented, and
and I want a road that So, I want a final
I want a road that So, I want a final itinerary that gives me that satisfies
itinerary that gives me that satisfies two constraints.
Yeah, that's not good, right? Okay.
Okay. New York and New York.
New York and New York. So,
So, if So, I want to see how fast I can get
if So, I want to see how fast I can get to my destination. That's my top
to my destination. That's my top priority. If I can get if I can get to
priority. If I can get if I can get to to New York at 5:00 p.m., I want to get
to New York at 5:00 p.m., I want to get there at 5:00 p.m.
there at 5:00 p.m. But if I have three I don't want to get
But if I have three I don't want to get there at 5:01, for example.
there at 5:01, for example. But if I have three ways to get there at
But if I have three ways to get there at 5:00 p.m., I want to choose the way
5:00 p.m., I want to choose the way that's the most eco-friendly. So, least
that's the most eco-friendly. So, least amount of fuel.
So, of all possible ways, the fastest way,
way, out of all possible fastest ways,
out of all possible fastest ways, the way that consumes the least fuel.
the way that consumes the least fuel. Least fuel.
Least fuel. Go.
Go. You have 2 minutes. Nice. Maybe five.
You have 2 minutes. Nice. Maybe five. Maybe five. And do we have the same
Maybe five. And do we have the same costs for the
costs for the So, each edge always has the same fuel
So, each edge always has the same fuel cost. Oh, it always But depending on
cost. Oh, it always But depending on when you start going across it, it's
when you start going across it, it's going to take a different time to So, we
going to take a different time to So, we don't know what those times are.
don't know what those times are. They're going to be different for each
They're going to be different for each edge. Mhm.
edge. Mhm. One guess, take Dijkstra, find the
One guess, take Dijkstra, find the shortest path length, and then look for
shortest path length, and then look for all path lengths through that length.
all path lengths through that length. I don't know. Uh so, we have the issue
I don't know. Uh so, we have the issue that I I might still have it. Oh, no,
that I I might still have it. Oh, no, never mind. Sorry, I erased it, so it's
never mind. Sorry, I erased it, so it's not on your mind anymore. We have those
not on your mind anymore. We have those diamonds that show you that there are
diamonds that show you that there are there might be an exponential number of
there might be an exponential number of paths with the same length
paths with the same length or the same distance.
or the same distance. it doesn't help that we know we should
it doesn't help that we know we should cut off it. Nope. Yeah. So, we need to
cut off it. Nope. Yeah. So, we need to do the process that I just erased. So,
do the process that I just erased. So, transform the graph in Right.
transform the graph in Right. So, the thing is now you're missing
So, the thing is now you're missing state, right? This misses state. This
state, right? This misses state. This tells you how many edges you have to get
tells you how many edges you have to get from source to destination. But we're
from source to destination. But we're not keeping track of some state that is
not keeping track of some state that is vital.
vital. So, transform the graph the graph to
So, transform the graph the graph to keep track of state, run say Dijkstra,
keep track of state, run say Dijkstra, and then interpret the output.
So, what state do we need? Let's think of that.
of that. Fuel cost, I think.
Fuel cost, I think. Sorry? Fuel cost is the same for each
Sorry? Fuel cost is the same for each edge.
edge. Mhm.
Mhm. Just the time is different.
Just the time is different. With the traffic.
With the traffic. But like don't you want to keep because
But like don't you want to keep because like once you have found the fastest
like once you have found the fastest path, then you want to like see like
path, then you want to like see like according to our fuel cost rating.
according to our fuel cost rating. Yep.
take So, won't we like
So, won't we like So, like
So, like thinking about the priority, our
thinking about the priority, our priority is time. Yep. So, we want to
priority is time. Yep. So, we want to like
like save fuel like I view like as a state
save fuel like I view like as a state to check it. Uh
to check it. Uh So, the problem is I don't even know if
So, the problem is I don't even know if fuel costs are integers, I can't keep
fuel costs are integers, I can't keep fuel as a state.
fuel as a state. So, how many copies would I have? For
So, how many copies would I have? For each vertex, how many copies would I
each vertex, how many copies would I have if fuel is a state? Who knows?
have if fuel is a state? Who knows? So, let's try something else.
So, let's try something else. But you're on the right track.
But you're on the right track. Let's take a variable and make it state.
So, for every vertex can you keep track of
how was the shortest time it took to get there?
time it took to get there? What's the shortest time it took to get
What's the shortest time it took to get there?
there? Uh
Uh So, how would you keep track of that?
So, how would you keep track of that? Would you make that state or how would
Would you make that state or how would you keep track of that?
I'm not disagreeing. I'm trying to understand your So, like for example,
understand your So, like for example, like
like let's say if you have B, right?
let's say if you have B, right? Okay.
Okay. say at vertex B, if you let's say it
say at vertex B, if you let's say it takes like one one hour to go from A to
takes like one one hour to go from A to B.
B. And so, when you when you So, it depends
And so, when you when you So, it depends when you start, by the way.
when you start, by the way. So, Right. how much time it takes
So, Right. how much time it takes depends on when you start. So, like if
depends on when you start. So, like if you start at 8:00 a.m., it might be an
you start at 8:00 a.m., it might be an hour. If you start at 8:00 at 9:00 a.m.,
hour. If you start at 8:00 at 9:00 a.m., it might be 2 hours. Right.
it might be 2 hours. Right. Do you need to have a finite number of
Do you need to have a finite number of states?
states? Uh it's nice if it's not infinite, but
Uh it's nice if it's not infinite, but it doesn't have to be constant like we
it doesn't have to be constant like we had before. It can be more than
had before. It can be more than constant, for sure.
constant, for sure. So, what are you thinking?
So, what are you thinking? I want to use time as a state. I like
I want to use time as a state. I like that idea. Let's try to do it.
that idea. Let's try to do it. So, we're going to use time as a state.
So, we're going to use time as a state. How many vertices am I going to have for
How many vertices am I going to have for each vertex?
each vertex? So, for each original vertex, how many
So, for each original vertex, how many vertices am I going to have in my new
vertices am I going to have in my new graph?
Three or four or zero.
or four or zero. I feel like it grows exponentially.
I feel like it grows exponentially. Well, I
So, if if I say, "Hey, I'm at this vertex at this time,"
vertex at this time," then I'm going to have M vertices for
then I'm going to have M vertices for each original vertex, right?
each original vertex, right? Right.
Right. So, I promised that the resolution of
So, I promised that the resolution of time is minutes.
time is minutes. So, I promised that
So, I promised that this thing gives you an integer number
this thing gives you an integer number of minutes.
of minutes. Can't be like
Can't be like in the days, though.
in the days, though. Suppose
Suppose uh suppose you can get from source to
uh suppose you can get from source to destination in one day.
destination in one day. So, let's see how it build this graph
So, let's see how it build this graph first, and then we can uh figure out the
first, and then we can uh figure out the rest of the things. So, for each node,
rest of the things. So, for each node, I'm going to make M copies of it.
I'm going to make M copies of it. So, suppose in my original graph I had a
So, suppose in my original graph I had a node,
node, I'm going to have M copies of that node,
I'm going to have M copies of that node, and each copy has the original vertex
and each copy has the original vertex and the time when I'm there.
and the time when I'm there. Right? So, there are V of these, and
Right? So, there are V of these, and there are
there are M of these.
Yes? So, that makes sense. It's a great idea.
So, that makes sense. It's a great idea. Yeah, you had it.
Yeah, you had it. Great idea.
Great idea. So far, so good. So,
Yeah, so let's see how we do that. Let's do that. So,
Let's do that. So, suppose we have an edge
suppose we have an edge from U to V,
from U to V, and
and uh yeah, how are we going to connect
uh yeah, how are we going to connect this? How are we going to transform
this? How are we going to transform this?
this? How many edges are we going to make from
How many edges are we going to make from that edge?
that edge? So, you need
You should only make Oh my goodness. Like do you have to do
Oh my goodness. Like do you have to do it from every start time? Like I guess.
it from every start time? Like I guess. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. So,
So, M edges is Okay.
M edges is Okay. M edges. So, from U
M edges. So, from U and a start time to
and a start time to V and what?
V and what? Uh T plus TC of T.
Uh T plus TC of T. T plus TC of going through that edge,
T plus TC of going through that edge, right? Mhm.
right? Mhm. TC of going from U to V at this time.
Right. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah, like this.
Yeah, like this. So, you start from a time. So, the edge
So, you start from a time. So, the edge points from the time that you start up
points from the time that you start up until the time when you'd be able to
until the time when you'd be able to finish.
finish. So up until the time where you'd be off
So up until the time where you'd be off the highway and done in the next city.
the highway and done in the next city. And we need one more type of edges.
And we need one more type of edges. There's one more tiny trick.
There's one more tiny trick. So if I'm somewhere in Massachusetts and
So if I'm somewhere in Massachusetts and I know that it's really bad now, I might
I know that it's really bad now, I might prefer to wait out for a few minutes, go
prefer to wait out for a few minutes, go to a bar and then come and drive. Okay,
to a bar and then come and drive. Okay, not to a bar. Go to a food place and
not to a bar. Go to a food place and then drive later.
then drive later. So edges that
So edges that represent waiting.
represent waiting. Yeah, they have one minute between them.
Yeah, they have one minute between them. Okay, so how do I do that?
Okay, so how do I do that? So from A from U to U Okay. with a cost
So from A from U to U Okay. with a cost of one.
of one. From U to U
From U to U Uh well, so from U at time T
Uh well, so from U at time T at time at time T
at time at time T to U at time T plus one. Okay, I like
to U at time T plus one. Okay, I like this better.
this better. And
And what's the fuel cost of this?
what's the fuel cost of this? zero cost
zero cost Okay. So here is this edge has fuel cost
Okay. So here is this edge has fuel cost of C and then you're just going to have
of C and then you're just going to have fuel cost
fuel cost for the ones on the top.
for the ones on the top. Is it proportional to minutes? Speed?
Is it proportional to minutes? Speed? It's the same.
It's the same. It's just FC. So FC stays the same no
It's just FC. So FC stays the same no matter when we go through the highway.
matter when we go through the highway. FC is a function of the distance of the
FC is a function of the distance of the road.
road. So this edge becomes M edges with the
So this edge becomes M edges with the same cost.
same cost. And then I have to have vertical waiting
And then I have to have vertical waiting edges.
So if we have the if we have the holographic display that I talked about
holographic display that I talked about earlier, you'd have
earlier, you'd have M sheets of paper this time.
M sheets of paper this time. You start at time zero at your source
You start at time zero at your source and then
and then your edges go represent the moves that
your edges go represent the moves that you could make. So you could start in
you could make. So you could start in Boston at 8:00 a.m. and you could take
Boston at 8:00 a.m. and you could take I-90 and end up in
I-90 and end up in I don't know. I don't know Massachusetts
I don't know. I don't know Massachusetts city names. Albuquerque at
city names. Albuquerque at 9:00 a.m.? Okay, I don't know. Sorry. I
9:00 a.m.? Okay, I don't know. Sorry. I don't
don't Amherst. Okay. So you start in Boston
Amherst. Okay. So you start in Boston 8:00 a.m. You end up at Amherst at I
8:00 a.m. You end up at Amherst at I don't know, 9:00 10:00 a.m. Right? So
don't know, 9:00 10:00 a.m. Right? So this is one edge.
this is one edge. So the edges represent the moves that
So the edges represent the moves that you could make in this graph.
Does this make sense? Wait, I I understand the two last lines
Wait, I I understand the two last lines there. What was the I don't really get
there. What was the I don't really get what you're you were doing there. Can
what you're you were doing there. Can you explain to Okay, so let's see what
you explain to Okay, so let's see what we're trying to do here. So we're saying
we're trying to do here. So we're saying that if I'm a node U Mhm. and
that if I'm a node U Mhm. and I'm starting at time T. Yeah, so it's
I'm starting at time T. Yeah, so it's like one one piece paper. Yep. Okay. So
like one one piece paper. Yep. Okay. So this is I'm going to go on the road,
this is I'm going to go on the road, right?
right? Mhm. I'm going to go on the road from U
Mhm. I'm going to go on the road from U to V. Mhm.
to V. Mhm. So where am I going to arrive?
So where am I going to arrive? There at V at some time. Right?
There at V at some time. Right? Right. So we now we have to figure out
Right. So we now we have to figure out what time we're going to arrive at.
what time we're going to arrive at. So the time that we arrive at is the
So the time that we arrive at is the original time
original time plus whatever time I'm going to spend on
plus whatever time I'm going to spend on the road. Mhm. What's the time I spend
the road. Mhm. What's the time I spend on the road? It's not constant because I
on the road? It's not constant because I have that timetable that includes
have that timetable that includes traffic. Yeah. So this is what this
traffic. Yeah. So this is what this tells me.
tells me. This is what this big ugly formula is
This is what this big ugly formula is all about.
all about. It says the timetable for this edge
It says the timetable for this edge assuming you start at time T. That's all
assuming you start at time T. That's all there is. Nothing else.
there is. Nothing else. What's the second line there?
What's the second line there? So the second line is waiting.
So the second line is waiting. Mhm. So if I don't have this then I'm
Mhm. So if I don't have this then I'm constrained in that I have to drive all
constrained in that I have to drive all the time.
the time. Right? I go from here to Amherst then I
Right? I go from here to Amherst then I have to go from Amherst to somewhere
have to go from Amherst to somewhere else and keep going keep going keep
else and keep going keep going keep going.
going. saying you need to use this is the this
saying you need to use this is the this is the pausing. Yeah, this is where I
is the pausing. Yeah, this is where I wait for a minute. Okay. So if I wait
wait for a minute. Okay. So if I wait for a minute, I don't consume any fuel
for a minute, I don't consume any fuel and I go from time T time T plus one.
and I go from time T time T plus one. It's half. Okay.
It's half. Okay. Does this make sense?
Does this make sense? Uh do we want to analyze the running
Uh do we want to analyze the running time for this really quickly? Sure.
time for this really quickly? Sure. So how many edges?
E times M Okay, let's do vertices because vertices is quick.
because vertices is quick. E times M Okay. So edges is you're
E times M Okay. So edges is you're saying E times M.
saying E times M. Almost. Pause there. Okay, so there's a
Almost. Pause there. Okay, so there's a pause, right? How many pause edges do I
pause, right? How many pause edges do I have? Um
have? Um Oh, V.
Oh, V. Um M
Okay, so this is how many vertices, this is how many edges. Plug this into which
is how many edges. Plug this into which algorithm? Dijkstra or Bellman-Ford?
algorithm? Dijkstra or Bellman-Ford? Dijkstra. All positive. Done.
Dijkstra. All positive. Done. Yay, we solved a hard problem. How do
Yay, we solved a hard problem. How do you
you How do you ensure that the time's right?
How do you ensure that the time's right? So do you have to go through
So do you have to go through and see if there's a path? How do you
and see if there's a path? How do you read the solution? That's good. That's a
read the solution? That's good. That's a good question. I like that.
good question. I like that. So we're going to have
So we're going to have M vertices at the destination, right?
M vertices at the destination, right? Let's see how they're going to look
Let's see how they're going to look like. First off, if you start at 8:00
like. First off, if you start at 8:00 a.m., maybe you're not going to make it
a.m., maybe you're not going to make it to New York at 8:01 a.m.
to New York at 8:01 a.m. So the verti- the vertex that says New
So the verti- the vertex that says New York at 8:01 a.m. is probably going to
York at 8:01 a.m. is probably going to have a cost of plus infinity.
have a cost of plus infinity. So first off, the really early times are
So first off, the really early times are going to have a cost of plus infinity.
going to have a cost of plus infinity. Not going to happen. Then at some point,
Not going to happen. Then at some point, the cost is going to become finite.
the cost is going to become finite. That's the fastest way you can get from
That's the fastest way you can get from Boston to New York.
Boston to New York. And in the shortest time. Uh sorry,
And in the shortest time. Uh sorry, using the least amount of fuel.
using the least amount of fuel. So the cost that you have there is the
So the cost that you have there is the answer to our problem.
answer to our problem. So basically when you get the result,
So basically when you get the result, you have to iterate through all M
you have to iterate through all M all M vertices that correspond to the
all M vertices that correspond to the destination.
destination. Right. Okay, so what I like about this
Right. Okay, so what I like about this is
is so the costs are going to look like
so the costs are going to look like this. They're going to be infinity
this. They're going to be infinity infinity infinity all the way up until
infinity infinity all the way up until some point. And here you're going to
some point. And here you're going to have your final answer. The cost to get
have your final answer. The cost to get there the fastest, say you can get there
there the fastest, say you can get there at 3:00 p.m.
at 3:00 p.m. This is how much fuel you're willing to
This is how much fuel you're willing to you have to spend to get there at 3:00
you have to spend to get there at 3:00 p.m. But if you want to if you're
p.m. But if you want to if you're willing to wait until 3:01 p.m.
willing to wait until 3:01 p.m. you're going to have the cost the
you're going to have the cost the fastest cost you can have for that. If
fastest cost you can have for that. If you're willing to wait until 3:02
you're willing to wait until 3:02 you're going to have the answer for
you're going to have the answer for that, too.
that, too. So here you're going to get the whole
So here you're going to get the whole trade-off curve of if you're willing to
trade-off curve of if you're willing to wait for a few minutes or if you're
wait for a few minutes or if you're willing to wait for an extra hour, how
willing to wait for an extra hour, how much fuel you can save.
So I think that's cool about that's cool about your
cool about that's cool about your question.
question. Okay. You had a question, too.
Okay. You had a question, too. Why did we have V times M in the E prime
Why did we have V times M in the E prime expression?
expression? So first off, we have E times M, right?
So first off, we have E times M, right? We're good with these.
We're good with these. These are the waiting edges.
These are the waiting edges. So you have waiting like after every
So you have waiting like after every minute or what? So the waiting edges are
minute or what? So the waiting edges are vertex time to vertex time plus one. How
vertex time to vertex time plus one. How many vertices?
many vertices? V. How many times?
V. How many times? M Okay, so it's V times M.
Because at each minute you can be at a certain city and decide to wait one more
certain city and decide to wait one more minute to stay in the same city.
Okay. Does this make sense? Thank you guys. I'm really happy we
Thank you guys. I'm really happy we solved a hard problem. That's good.